Williamsburg Brooklyn is a launch pad
for trends especially when it comes to
fashion it's also home to urban
outfitters concept store the company's
testing ground for the hottest new thing
in retail
since skinny jeans I love them to fit on
yay thank you
they're called beacons tiny little low
energy devices that push messages to
your phone via bluetooth
now you can explore what we have here at
face anyway as you make your way through
the store beacons can send you alerts
promotions even guidance based on your
location little short for hop hop slim
boyfriend Jean perfect I do the very
skinny boyfriend not my little racy
that's not for work all right I can wear
this the range can even be specified to
notify shoppers in designated areas like
the fitting room
we got a winner here shoppers are
encouraged to be social how to make an
Instagram where are they here
apparently this is a very popular thing
to do hashtag you owe on you has been
used almost fifty five thousand times
why do you think that using this beacon
technology makes sense for who the urban
shopper is we know that they're already
on their phones when they walk in the
store their phone is out we have welcome
messages which can be anything from you
know this is your this is your store
here's let's hear like the space 98
message or if we have some sort of sale
that we want to push we can do that
there we can also push in-store events
which is really cool and it's something
our store associates love so I walk in
the store I get a message that says
Pancho's 50% off and guess what there's
van plain tonight exactly not since the
arrival of credit card readers has
in-store technology caught on this fast
the number installed in u.s. doors is
expected to go from nil to over 3 mil in
just a few years already big name chains
are testing them out and among top 100
retailers 85 percent could be using
beacons by 2016 when we send a push
message to a customer's in-store we're
seeing a 60 to 70 70 % aggregated
engagement rate Wow opening the push
message that gets triggered by a beacon
interaction and we can compare that to
generic push messaging which we see at
like a 12 percent engagement rate and
even mobile advertising which is much
lower critically what is the conversion
rate from those people who open up the
notifications into sales so where we are
specifically targeting a transaction the
redemption rate isn't between 30 and 35
percent Wow